ستكون هذه إحدى الصور التي
تحدد حرب فلاديمير بوتين على
أوكرانيا ووحشيتها
، حيث كانت أم مصابة بالكدمات وضمادات تطعم طفلها
البالغ من العمر شهرًا ،
ومن المحتمل أن تنقذ بطولة الأم حياة الطفل.
يقترب القصف
بشكل جيد بعد أن
تم إطلاق النار على نوافذ وأبواب المبنى المجاور ،
وأصيب الزوجان بشظايا زجاج
أولجا تحمي الرضيعة
بجسدها ولم يصاب الطفل بجروح ولكن كلا
الوالدين كانا ويتعافيان جميعًا
في مستشفى كييف
لا تصدق
كما تعلم أننا نفكر دائمًا في
إبقاء بوتين خططه قريبة من سترته
ولكنك تحدثت
عن وجود الكثير بالفعل في
المجال العام الذي
قاله بوتين علنًا أو كتب عنه ، فما
الذي يمكننا استخلاصه من ذلك
نعم أه بوتين نشر كتبًا
ومقالات ومن الواضح أنه ألقى العديد من الخطب
أه بما في ذلك ما قبل الحرب
في أوكرانيا.
r وكيف يفكر في
زمن الحرب ، من الواضح أن الحرب العالمية الثانية كانت
محكًا متكررًا في تفكيره أن
عائلته عانت كثيرًا في حصار
لينينغراد ويؤكد على
التضحيات العظيمة للشعب الروسي يقول
إن الجميع يرتكبون أخطاء في الحرب ولكن
يمكنك ذلك  لا يسهب في الحديث عما يقوله
عندما تقاتل إذا واصلت
التفكير في الأخطاء من حولك ، فلن
تفوز أبدًا ، عليك أن تستمر في التفكير في
النصر وعندما يتذكر حملته
الوحشية في الشيشان في أواخر
التسعينيات ، يقول.  عليك أن تظل حازمًا ،
يكتب أنه إذا أصبحت متوترًا ،
فسوف يعتقد أعداؤك أنهم
أقوى ، الشيء الوحيد الذي ينجح هو
شن الهجوم عليك أن تضرب
أولاً وتضرب بقوة حتى
لا يرتفع خصومك إلى أقدامهم.
كتابات على الأقل يحب أن يرسم
نفسه على أنه هذا الرقم الذي لا يُقاوم